- [Robin] Welcome to
Tasty's nacho cook-Off.
Three members of the Tasty team face off
to see who can make the best nachos.
Competing in this event
are Robin Broadfoot,
Tasty video producer,
Hannah Williams, Tasty video producer,
and Nick Guillory, Tasty
social media strategist.
(upbeat surfer music)
So today I'm making
steak and potato nachos,
so I made this into a
video and once it was made,
I usually like to take my food home,
but in this case, it didn't happen,
because all my coworkers ate it.
I've got three russet potatoes,
which I'm going to season
with olive oil, salt, pepper and paprika.
I'll bake the potatoes at 450
degrees for about 20 minutes.
While that's cooking, I'm
going to season the steak and
get a nice sear on them roughly
three minutes each side.
I'll flip the steak once.
After that, I'll let the steak
rest for eight to 10 minutes
because it's still cooking after
you take it out of the pan.
Once the potatoes are
ready, I'm going to lay them
around the cast iron pan and
sprinkle the steak on them.
When everything's assembled,
I'm gonna cover the dish
with freshly grated cheddar
and Monterey Jack cheese.
And then I'm just gonna
boil it seven to 10 minutes
until everything's nice and
melted and then top it off
with sour cream and salsa and serve it.
When I was younger, I wasn't
really allowed in the kitchen.
My mom would always shoo me away,
but then going to college,
my dad said this would be
a good way to go on dates,
if women knew you could cook.
- [Hannah] Today I'm making
Korean pork belly nachos.
I make a lot of desserts for Tasty.
I'm kind of known for making cheesecake.
This is a little out of my comfort zone.
So the first thing I'm gonna do
is get this pork in the marinade.
It's gonna marinate in some
kimchi juice, soy sauce,
sesame oil, Korean red pepper, and honey.
Then I'm gonna sear it on
extremely high heat to try to
render the fat a little bit
to get it nice and crispy.
And while that cooks, I'm
gonna dice my toppings.
I got some red onions, some
kimchi, and I'll layer that
on top of the pork and the chips.
I'm gonna grate some
cheddar and Monterey Jack
and let that melt on top of the nachos.
And then my finishing touches
are gonna be some diced
tomatoes and green onions
and that's gonna go on top of
everything once it's melted.
And I'm gonna mix some sour
cream with kimchi juice
and drizzle that on top
as a finishing touch
to tie it all together.
When I think of nachos, I
think of kind of the standard
salsa, beans, cheese,
whatever you like on that,
so this is just a really,
really different type of nacho.
It's not too loaded, it's not too heavy,
but it still has a lot of flavor.
- [Nick] Hi, I'm Nick and I'm making
spicy, cheesy, blackened
chicken nachos today.
These guys cook like this all the time.
This is my first time like
cooking with all these cameras
and these fancy lights
and these microphones.
Like I'm not gonna lie, I'm scared.
I'm gonna season my chicken
with cajun seasoning,
garlic powder, chili
powder, and hot sauce.
While that's cooking, I'm
going to cut up some onions,
tomatoes, jalapenos, and corn.
I'll saute those veggies
with more cajun seasoning.
I'll add the blackened
chicken to the mixture
and top it all off with freshly grated
pepper jack cheese and salsa.
Broil that until the cheese is melted.
I'm from Louisiana and I love spicy food.
I like to entertain at home.
This will be like a cute little appetizer,
get everybody nice and
spicy and moving around,
and hot and sweaty before we go dancing.
(upbeat surfer music)
- [Taste-Tester 1] What kind
of beautiful mess is this
that I walked into?
- [Taste-Tester 2] That's
exactly what nachos are,
a beautiful mess.
- [Taste-Tester 1] This is real crunchy.
It's got a nice crunch to it.
- [Taste-Tester 3] Got
a nice crunch to it.
- [Taste-Tester 2] I
love this, but it doesn't
have that classic nacho cheese.
- [Taste-Tester 3] Yeah.
- [Taste-Tester 1] It's
very original though.
Okay, let's go to the next one.
It almost functions kind of like a dip.
This looks like a little bit
of salsa, a little cheese.
That is delicious.
- [Taste-Tester 2] It is spicy, though.
- [Taste-Tester 1] This is the perfect
ratio of cheese right here.
Steak!
- [Taste-Tester 2] Steak and potatoes.
- [Taste-Tester 1] I want this so badly.
- [Taste-Tester 2] Are you kidding me?
- [Taste-Tester 1]
There's a lot of cheese.
- [Taste-Tester 2] Oh
wait, are there no chips?
Can we all agree though if this one had
crispy potato chips, it would win?
- [Taste-Tester 3] For sure, the flavors
in this one was on point.
- [Taste-Tester 1] Mainly
we're just thankful that
they made this food for us.
- [Taste-Tester 3] I can't stop eating.
- [Taste-Tester 2] Yeah, I'm
just gonna keep eating it.
My winner, my decision is this guy.
- [Taste-Tester 1] Mine
is the blackened chicken.
- [Taste-Tester 2] Angela?
- [Angela] Mine was the
blackened chicken, as well.
- [Nick] Yeah! I won, I
won, I win everything.
Yes, what do I win?
(upbeat surfer music)
- [Narrator] Oh yes!